welcome to this video yes first game is
against psycho cowboy Graham master
Simon Williams young he's going for the
Dutch and the French yeah his classical
Dutch I don't really have a good lining
and said I have to admit it's not the
greatest opening other but it's not that
bad and I really don't have something
they're going to planar in the simple
fashion here let's see maybe he's going
form for this 45 probably is going for a
fire do I get any for quickly mmm like
c3 Quincy to e4 yeah this is really not
the way to tackle this opening but it's
solid I mean cackling I mean you can
play that what I do here with white but
it's not very ambitious I'm a bit
surprised that he went with this setup
thought I thought more flat d6 and e5
but well okay he can't play what what he
what he did it's not not awful anything
it's just not expecting it okay maybe I
can get something with a four a five
here not sure that he wants to play
Knight to c6 blocking this diagonal nope
hmm what did let looks fairly fairly
nice now we have got a five
yeah that's just use this stone wall
structure looks looks quite quite
pleasant for white nothing spectacular
but it's it's nice yeah it's not a pure
stone wall as a pawn on c5 of course but
we're close to that yeah okay um I can
go F for I can take and player 4 let's
take and play a form or actually before
before is also more I one now now let's
go ahead it's often a good idea to paint
simply block the whole business before
it's not turn it's not critical okay and
wonder what is idea is Bishop a six
maybe ok let's see that Bishop a six is
not coming and okay what is he doing
take cannot really take oh so okay I
want to go I want to go g4 so let's
prepare
and doubling on the G file he might play
c4 and be high if this kind of thing
trying to open the B file up but then
his Bishop is really bad OS Bishop c6
the idea I'm just attacking a form at
the moment that Bishop f4 wouldn't even
threaten something because of looking
for Queenie for Bishop behind not now k
Bishop sizzix he can do that but that
looks very risky stealing pawns there
yeah he's still going for it hmm so I
can't play bishops it too if I like but
he has be five then the a g4 is not
directly threatening much that sir
that's really true you can just stay put
it doesn't have to take
hmm can I one known
if I go gye takes it I take a can take
with the rook on a faulty maybe has c4
and stuff like that I know F Bishop see
to rook takes Queen takes Bishop b5
queen bee three rook a 14 look III
trapping the Queen I don't see how he
saves the Queen how does he save the
queen Bishop f4 okay for Bishop b5 queen
bee three okay one takes things
I don't see how okay that took me ages I
saw the idea right away but I wasn't I
wasn't confident now whatever i don't i
don't know don't know and he's playing
that very quickly to see every
reputation maybe he's giving up my mess
maybe that crank issues or something see
for Bishop f4 and Luke f3 is the threat
and Bishop f4 as the threat so no Bishop
f4 is no threat because of Quincy for so
we should pay for only in case of C
phone yeah well look III is what I saw
initially yeah I don't see how he saves
the Queen if he takes on d4 like cd4 I
can play ed for and he might take on c3
with the rook lucky gaining some ponds
that that's really possible if it takes
on default like cd4 look III then that
looks risky Queen a three and then d
takes c3 so after cd4 I have to take ed
form so what is the plan look III you're
going to maybe he's trying to install
app on their own b3 I like after c4
takes takes but I have Bishop d7
okay that's also a possibility Bishop d7
was my idea attacking the pawns directly
check yes that's an interesting IDM
let's take check can cheek I wonder if I
can take a five and pinion cover it like
that probably probably not King King g3
that's probably a better idea pin rooks
II to Queen B 52 d7 going for an attack
or can I can I winporn cm be a bishop
t5s better rugby to Bishop t5 and then
I'm taking be three next I should get
rid of the person that's that's more
important
time warning
you know okay that do it for
and I'm up on time now that's very
helpful Lucas III but this back rank is
kind of weak
okay can check here then should check
first maybe black resins and Bishop she
ate is made in a couple of moves chan I
don't know it was tricky but I think the
Queen was trapped I think it really was
trapped maybe he could sell he could
kind of get more for it I wasn't I
wasn't really sure g4 he took it yeah
maybe there's some kind of some kind of
glitch to the habit I thought it was
interesting I you know what I didn't see
at all Queen eight you create you as
possible I didn't think about that when
I have Bishop d7 I mean I saw that i
always have this move kind of as we in
in reserve but yeah that is that's
actually possible it's not check that
bad but I didn't really anticipate this
thing mm-hmm that looks fine from like I
don't think that this is particularly
great the comp gives black a slight
advantage for what it's worth have a
pond and that's that's maybe what he
what he needs to do after after this
rucca one and it looks kind of tricky
now the computer finds the defense this
loses this this and Roxy for that's it
at school
that's very nice here just a nice block
move look a three the bishop hangs if i
take he can shake and now a screen is
not trapped anymore the very sharp
position is success hanging the computer
of course just give 0 0 0 because is he
calculates some kind of Perpetual i can
also play this move and renew the threat
of ruby three but then he's stepping
back yeah giving giving him this square
and we have a very weird perpetual i was
also thinking roots III might be tricky
at least let's check this takes takes
takes hear me chef and now what rook
some well this is still very tricky to
play in the Blitz game hmm that's not
clear to me it can check here takes okay
he only has two pawns but I have Queenie
five that's important yeah okay but my
pieces are not badly coordinated but
it's not not so easy if you haven't even
this kind of thing might be not so easy
I have the wrong the wrong pawn them the
H pawn that should be winning but kind
of tricky yeah in the game nothing
nothing much happened really this is
really just just the crack check I think
that was was okay i get i get the pawn
there on b3 and this is the most
important thing killing his counter play
yeah my opening wasn't wasn't really
very ambitious what he does is see place
with with much success in place them the
classical dutch there this line Bishop
g7 here b7 this kind of thing he has two
books out on the subject at least two
books maybe more and yeah I really don't
know it very well I have
ideas but nothing that I feel is very
very great so I went with this very
simple setup I was actually expecting
something like this like d6 not that to
be 6 is bad i was just i would say i
expected this kind of thing to happen
with the idea of playing a quick I'm
sorry screwed my window up here it's a
bit better with the idea of going for
quickie 5 that was more what I expected
as suspected is by expected yeah and c5
that was a bit surprising for me that he
went with that no D hive young okay this
it is very equal I thought that he might
might might be a little bit better but
honestly he s c5 and that's not even a
normal stone wall and he can trade off
everything that appears only five so we
saw in the game he was okay it just has
to be technically a bit more precise
than not get his Queen trimmed okay well
thanks for watching